- [Narrator] This Great Big
Story was made possible,
by the Singapore Tourism Board.
- Hip-hop is the truest representation
of who you are and where you're from.
I grew up experiencing
this beautiful duality
of Tamil and English.
Tamil is one of the five
most commonly spoken Indian languages.
Tamil is a huge part of who I am,
and when I chose to pursue music,
I could not do it without
Tamil being in the picture.
(funky music)
My name is Yung Raja.
I'm a Singaporean rapper.
I rap in English and Tamil.
My family moved from South India
to Singapore in 1992.
Growing up, I spent most of
my time thinking in Tamil
and writing in Tamil.
For me, it was an idea
mixing the Tamil that I know;
how do we put that and English
into the equation of hip-hop?
That was the question that
I was trying to solve.
The first ever experiment we did,
was to make a remix of
Lil Pump's “Gucci Gang,”
and we called it “Poori Gang,”
and poori is a very famous Indian dish.
That was very well received.
The blend of Tamil and
English is just seamless;
you don't feel like I'm mixing
another foreign language.
♪ Mustafa by Yung Raja ♪
Something really interesting
has been happening recently,
with the world of hip-hop.
You see people like Rich Brian,
you see people like Higher Brothers
that pursue hip-hop and rap
with their mother tongue.
There's something very unique about this
because Asian hip-hop, I
think, is so, so beautiful.
You are adding another
language that carries
so many stories, so much
history, so much heritage.
So that's like, that changes the game.
This is the greatest thing about hip-hop:
when you let people know where you're from
and what you stand for
and what you represent,
people respect you.
Peace, it's your boy, Yung Raja.